Marvel didn't wait too long to give us our
first look at the upcoming ​The Eternals.​
Concept art for the flick, which will be the
second film in the MCU's Phase 4, was recently
released online.
It depicts a quartet of the ancient beings
known as Celestials walking across the surface
of a barren planet.
We've been introduced to these beings just
a couple of times before, once in each of
the Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
In Guardians Vol. 1, our heroes traveled to
the mining colony of Exitar to meet with The
Collector, who had some knowledge to impart
about the Infinity Stones.
Exitar is situated within Knowhere, which
is actually the severed head of a deceased
Celestial.
A later scene also seemed to showcase a look
at a Celestial as it uses the Power Stone
to effortlessly destroy an entire planet.
“These powerful carriers can destroy entire
civilizations like wheat in a field.”
In Guardians Vol. 2, we got our first proper
introduction to one of the all-powerful entities
in the form of Ego, the "Living Planet," who
was revealed to be the father of Peter Quill.
Ego didn't look a lot like the Celestials
pictured, but we can assume that Celestials
come in all shapes and sizes.
Plus, we can assume from Ego's ability to
masquerade as a human that Celestials can
also assume other forms if need be.
In Marvel lore, the Celestials existed before
virtually any other form of sentient life
in the universe.
Millions of years ago, they were responsible
for the creation of the Eternals — near-immortal,
superpowered humanoids — and their polar
opposite race, the Deviants, which are essentially
the Eternal equivalent of mutants.
The two races have been locked in struggle
for centuries, with the Eternals tasked with
defending Earth from the Deviants' conquest.
Thus far in the MCU, we haven't met any Eternals
that we know of, but we have met one Deviant.
Thanos, the Mad Titan who embarked on a quest
to collect all six Infinity Stones and wipe
out half of all life in the universe, carries
the Deviant gene in Marvel comics.
It's not yet known to what extent the Celestials
will figure into the narrative of The Eternals;
Marvel’s head honcho Kevin Feige has hinted
that the flick could be an epic spanning tens
of thousands of years, so we may only get
a look at them in the form of some exposition
on the ancient history of the universe.
As for the Eternals themselves, we at least
have an idea of what the team that will be
featured in the movie will look like, thanks
to Marvel's recent panel at San Diego Comic-Con
2019.
The entire primary cast was announced at the
event, and it includes Richard Madden as Ikaris,
the leader of the flick's team of heroes;
Angelina Jolie as Thena, also known as Azura,
who in the comics has been known to consort
with Deviants; Kumail Nanjiani as Kingo, who
took up residence in Japan thousands of years
ago and learned the ways of the Samurai; Lauren
Ridloff as Makkari, an expert mechanical engineer
and speedster; Brian Tyree Henry as Phastos,
a master weapons-smith; Salma Hayek as Ajak,
who has spent most of her thousands of Earthly
years in Siberia; finally young Lia McHugh
as Sprite, a trickster who is forever stuck
with the appearance of a pre-teen child.
The Eternals begins shooting next month, so
hopefully, it won't be too long before some
unofficial set photos of the stars in costume
arrive.
Of course, there will probably be plenty more
of these interesting little hints and revelations
that will come trickling out in the wake of
Marvel's epic Comic-Con panel.
We'll keep our eye out for them, and keep
you up to date.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.